Je venais d'une famille d'universitaires et
j'avais très peur d'être pris au
sérieux.
[Musique] [
Musique]
J'étais tellement excité à 13 ans lorsque le film est
sorti et que mon travail et mon art
auraient une réponse humaine. J'ai ouvert avec enthousiasme
mon premier courrier de fans.  lire un fantasme de viol
qu'un homme m'avait écrit
[Musique]
Je joue depuis l'âge de 11 ans mais je
pensais que jouer était trop frivole et
certainement pas significatif quand je suis arrivé à
Harvard juste après la sortie de
l'épisode Star Wars  Je savais que j'allais
recommencer en ce qui concerne la façon dont les gens
me percevaient. J'avais
peur que les gens supposent que j'étais
entré juste pour être célèbre.
[Musique]
J'ai été végétarien presque toute ma
vie et végétalien depuis six ans
et je  Je suis de plus en plus attaché à l'
idée que la façon dont nous traitons les animaux est
étroitement liée à notre relation
avec le monde.
[Musique]
J'aime évidemment ce pays, mais je suis
aussi assez critique à son égard, car je pense que
tout citoyen engagé devrait être aussi
critique à son égard.  les choses que vous pensez que
votre pays ne fait pas au mieux de
ses capacités
[Musique]
vous avez dit au monde que le temps était à la
violence vous avez dit au monde que le temps
était au silence
[Musique]